last week conan you mentioned how your
voice is an immediate boner killer and
is sterilizing
men throughout the world and you said
that you might try reading some erotic
fiction
as an example of what you mean yeah i
think this will prove my point
by the way i had to come back and put
this disclaimer in that some of the
language you're going to hear isn't safe
for children although the tone
is very safe for children here we go
show me how you pleasure yourself keep
still we're going to have to work on
keeping you still baby
let's see if we can make you come like
this you're so deliciously wet god i
want you
i'm going to [ __ ] you now miss steel
hard come for me anna
anyone aroused i don't think so no oh my
god here we go
i pull him deeper into my mouth so i can
feel him at the back of my throat no
end to the front again my tongue swirls
around the end
i can't he's my very own christian gray
flavored popsicle
i suck harder and hotter my inner
goddess is doing the meringue with some
salsa moves
here we go some more here's the old
climax you're going to take this and
like it
get your hands do it he leans down and
kisses me his fingers still moving
rhythmically inside me his thumb
circling and pressing his other hand
scoops my hair off my head and holds my
head in place
his tongue mirrors the actions of his
fingers claiming me my legs begin to
stiffen as i push against his head
he gentles his hands so i'm brought back
from the brain i come instantly again
and again falling apart beneath him then
i'm building again i climb back to new
calling out his name
suddenly he grabs me tipping me across
his lap with one smooth movement he
angles his body so my torso is resting
on the bed beside him
he throws his right leg not his left is
right over both
holding me down so i can move he places
his hand on my naked behind so there's
no clothing on that behind it's as naked
as the day i was born
wearing my birthday suit i tell you he's
softly fondling me stroking around and
around with his flat palm
and then his hand is no longer there
what happened is it a magic trick nope
then he hits me hard that's right he
hits me but in a way that's not creepy
at all
we lie there pending together waiting
for our breathing to slow he gently
strokes my hair
boy i survived that wasn't so bad i'm
more stoic than i thought my inner
goddess is prostrate well at least she's
quiet
that's awful that is awesome i want to
read i want to
i want to read i want to do the
audiobook for this no
that was terrible sitting beside me he
gently pulls my sweatpants down
up and down like a [ __ ] drawers a
horse drawers
what does that mean what is that a horse
who's called them drawers in 150 years
like a horse draws my subconscious
remarks bitterly
in my head i tell her where to go
christian squirts baby oil into his hand
and then rubs
my behind with careful tenderness from
makeup remover to soothing bone for a
spanked ass
who'da thought it was such a versatile
liquid what it sounds like an ad
it's a versatile liquid
[Music]
from remover to soothing bomb for a
spanked ass wow what a versatile liquid
you want some you can get it here
order now on amazon
oh oh my god that was traumatizing for
me
here we go oh there's moors please i
can't stop ugh
he holds out his hand and his palm are
two shiny silver balls linked with a
thick black bead
no inside me i gasp and all the muscles
deeply in my belly clench
no my inner goddess is doing the dance
of the seven veils oh my
now it's a curious feeling when they're
inside me i can't really feel them
but then again i know they're there oh
my well i have to keep these they make
me needy uh needy for sex if i wasn't
clear
yes the neediness is for sex
wow i never needed to hear that